il existe 26 centres de planification
familiale dans les yvelines géré par le
conseil général comme ici à trappes dans
ces lieux une équipe composée d'un
médecin et d'une conseillère conjugale
et familiale conseil qui veut sur la
sexualité offre un accès à la
contraception et au dépistage des
maladies sexuellement transmissibles
on parle souvent de libération des
moeurs et pourtant face à ces
questionnements rien n'a vraiment changé
chez des jeunes
la sexualité ça reste un sujet tabou ça
reste un sujet difficile à aborder soit
parce que les parents veulent pas
entendre parler ou ne peuvent pas
entendre parler enfin les jeunes et soit
parce que parfois les jeunes ne veulent
pas encore en parler parce que c'est
leur intimité ils savent beaucoup plus
de choses ils ont ils ont toujours du
mal à mettre en pratique mais ils savent
ils savent des choses ils savent que la
pilule et tous les mois une
contraception a dit koné s'y connaissent
les préservatifs la mise le passage à
l'acte à la mise en pratique est plus
compliqué les centres de planification
familiale à ne pas confondre avec le
planning familial qui est une
association sont mal connus des jeunes
générations et pourtant ici les
entretiens sont gratuits et
confidentiels
un colloque sur ce thème s'est déroulée
à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin l'adulte et un
rôle important à jouer dans la
transmission des informations
c'est le message de ce professeur il ya
moins d'autorité naturelle et surtout
les beaucoup d'adultes ne se sentent
plus légitime au fonds d'intervenir
c'est peut-être là ils sous estiment
l'importance qu'ils ont pour les ados
beaucoup d'adolescents sensibles ont
peur de la déception est à la place il
s'enferme dans des comportements qu'ils
pensent maîtriser mais qui en général ne
les empêche de se nourrir justement des
échanges qu'il pourrait les valoriser
leur donner confiance en 2011 les 26
centres de planification des yvelines
ont reçu 8500 personnes est assurée
14000 consultation un projet est en
cours pour diminuer le nombre de ses
centres mais leur permettre d'être
ouvert du lundi au vendredi ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui